you're listening to an encore
presentation of Bible answers live
however if you want to order any
materials offered during tonight's
program you may call our resource number
anytime at
[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
hello friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact in the early 1800s
communications in America were carried
by foot horse or train across the
country depending on road conditions or
whether it could take days or weeks to
get a message
but then in 1832 Samuel Morse an
accomplished American painter while
visiting France was inspired about an
idea he heard of an electric telegraph
Moore spent the next 12 years perfecting
a working Telegraph instrument and
during the same period he also composed
a digital language better known as Morse
code a set of short and long dot and
dash signals that could represent
different letters and numbers in a
telegraph message Morse eventually
convinced Congress to finance a
Washington to Baltimore telegraph line
that on May 24 1844 in a public
demonstration he inaugurated the world's
first commercial Telegraph Morse relayed
the message what hath God wrought a
quote taken from numbers 23 23 was very
fitting giving the inventions future
world impact just a decade after this
first line opened more than 20 thousand
miles of telegraph cable crisscross the
country empowering American expansion
today international communications
travel at the speed of light but you
know the Bible tells about an even
faster method of communication stay with
his friends were going to learn more on
this edition of Bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 my name is
John Ross good evening friends and also
our friends joining us on Facebook this
evening again welcome the life did you
part of our Bible answers live program
pastor Doug is always let's stop with a
word of Prayer dear father we thank you
for the opportunity that we have to open
up your word and study together we ask
your blessing upon this program be with
those who are listening and father as we
always ask lead us into a clear
understanding of the Bible as we study
together in Jesus name Amen amen
well pastor Doug it's kind of
interesting in today's world we take for
granted all of this sudden
communications it's quite true that
something might occur in your hometown
and people on the other side of the
world might hear about it before you
actually find out about it because of
the way things travel and speed and
satellites and the internet and all of
those things in the phone but back in
1844 I guess it was a real big deal if
you could send a message I had a later
or just shot in really loud you know I
been reading some books from the period
before that I were just finishing a book
by about John Adams and some other books
about Jefferson and and they would write
messages to Europe and if the ship where
the mail went down they
didn't even know who was president and I
mean weeks would go by months would go
by they take could you please do this or
that and they would wait six months for
an answer
it was amazing so with the electronic
communications it really did
revolutionize the world and that simple
invention of sending messages through a
series of you ever seen someone operate
a new code operating yeah I had a ham
radio friend and he would sit there with
his little Telegraph and he would still
send out code around the world with her
ham radio and I don't know how he ever
could decode it but he would sit there
with a pencil and write down the letters
and get the messages and of course the
most famous code of all is SOS save our
souls I guess that's right the
international code and that's sort of
how to out of the Titanic nets but
particular that grew out of the Titanic
but we were talking about a method of
communication that's even faster you
know you can read in the Book of Daniel
chapter 9 at the beginning of the
chapter Daniel starts to pray by the end
of chapter 9 the angel Gabriel comes and
Gabriel says at the beginning of your
prayer God sent me to come to you and
give you a message
and you think how big is space how far
away is heaven wherever that is angels
must go really fast and prayer must go
really fast and just think about it
friends if you had the smartest
smartphone it's not smart enough to
connect you to God that prayer is a
device that will put you in touch with
the Almighty and you don't need an
appointment you can go in Jesus name
directly to the creator of the cosmos
and he'll listen to you and yet we pray
so little and God is more willing to
answer your prayers than you are to ask
them so would you like to know more
about the power of prayer we have a
special gift we have a book that's
called teach us to pray and this is our
free gift for anybody who'd call and ask
for it just a great resource giving you
some biblical principles on prayer if
you'd like to receive the gift give us a
call on our resource phone line that
number is eight hundred four six three
seven two nine seven actually that's the
number here to our studio for the free
book the number to call is 883
five six seven four seven and just asked
for the book called teach us to pray
again that number is 885 six seven four
seven as for the book teach us to pray
we'll be able to send that to anybody
who calls and asks I think we're ready
for the phone lines our first caller
this evening let's see if we've got
Ronde listening from North Carolina
Ronde welcome to the program hi good
evening pastor Bachelor Pastor Ross hey
I've gotten a couple of quick questions
stop dealing with bishops and I only
found them really in three three books
of the three chapters ah let's see
first Timothy three and one Titus one is
seven and first Peter and it basically
compared them to an overseer could you
tell me what's the difference between a
bishop and overseer probably nothing a
matter of fact there's three three words
that you'll find sometimes it calls an
elder a bishop and overseer as Paul went
from church to church Paul was in a
tenant apostle on evangelist he would go
raise up churches then he would organize
the church and he would appoint and they
often did this by the laying on of hands
a bishop or an elder that would be the
basically the pastor I was part of a
group that did an extensive Bible study
it was a group of 10 people at Andrews
University where we delved into was
there a difference between a pastor an
elder bishop
they're essentially the same thing
they're just different words that are
used to describe the leaders of the
churches in in the early days so it's
the same word and then he gives the you
know the definition the bishop must be
blameless the husband of one wife
temperate sober-minded good behavior so
forth so I don't know if that's
answering specifically what you're
asking though
yeah well it's dealing with also
Catholics and the word bishop and it's
like used exclusively by the Catholics
and I want to tie this in real quickly
I've notice a lot of churches now are
beginning to dress like Catholics and is
that a sound symbolizing Babylon and her
daughters
alright well you know you are correct
that in some denominations they reserve
the word Bishop for a certain hierarchy
of clergy and then they've got Cardinals
occur then to get the Pope in some
churches or they've got the patriarch if
you're in the Orthodox Church but you
know in the Bible it didn't really make
that kind of distinction
you had the pastors and elders were
basically the same pastors all those
bishops were the leaders of the church
then you had apostles and you know
there's a limited number of those oh
those are the ones who had actually seen
Jesus in that first generation so and
then as far as the robes go well you
know God did have the priests wear
special garments but we are not part of
the Levitical priesthood anymore and we
believe that Peter James John the
Apostles they disappeared in a crowd
because they dress like everybody else
they didn't even know who Jesus was
until Judas came and identified him
because he does he wasn't wearing any
kind of special robes the Bible never
mentions I only think it says about his
robe as it was seamless it never says it
was a priestly robe or anything so if my
church has been in to dress like that
with the back what collars and all this
stuff looking like a Catholic I should
stay or should I perhaps look for
another church well you know I can't
speak to that I you know there's a place
in a time for a uniform I do think that
pastors should dress in especially when
they're ministering on Sabbath they
should dress in a respectful way but you
know if people are starting to get into
external display then that would be that
would be a problem I think but yeah I
can't tell you where God wants you you
want to be where they're following the
word Ronde and I hope that helps a
little bit
I just don't want to be part of the
daughters of Babylon yeah I know
well I'll pray that God guides you in
that thank you you're welcome thank you
for your call appreciate that
next hole that we have is Roger
listening from Denver Colorado Roger
welcome to the program
thank you for having me hi pastor got a
question somebody told me in the Bible
and Revelation 13 11 through 18 I think
it is it mentions a country but some
people say it's Israel or another
country is it not my belief that it is
America revelation 18 was talking about
Babylon
no revelation 13 or 13
well the firt there's two beasts in
Revelation 13 the first beast you see is
talking about the religious power in
Europe with its seat in Rome I don't
think I need to say much more about that
No
then it says there's a you go to verse
11 it says I saw another beast coming up
out of the earth with two horns like a
lamb and he spoke like a dragon we
believe that's talking about the United
States of America
and the US has become the the seat it's
the strongest Confederacy of Protestants
in the world where Europe became the
seat of Catholicism in the Orthodox
churches and they're going to form a
union that is going to become a
persecuting power in the last days so
yeah you know right now the thing to
keep in mind when you look at the second
beast in Revelation 13 11 so he starts
out with two horns like a lamb now in
the Bible a lamb is a good thing
a dragon is a bad thing and so he starts
out with the power of Christ and freedom
of religion freedom of government those
are probably the two horns but then he
speaks he begins to legislate like a
dragon like a devil and the beasts power
and it starts to persecute and there's
signs and wonders I think we're living
in on the verge of that right now you
know we do have a study guide called the
u.s. in Bible prophecy that really gets
into this passage of Scripture in
Revelation chapter 13 much more detail
we were happy to send that to anybody
who calls and asks the number is 883
five six seven four seven you just ask
for the study guide called the u.s. in
Bible prophecy I'll be happy to send
that out next one of that we have is
Chris listening from Carmichael yes
pastors thank you so much for doing this
show it's very much appreciated
pleasure my question was science is
discovering new things each week and
this is stai pathetical let's say they
found a pill that would if you're 60
years old and you took it
your body would regress back to 30 years
old is there anything in the Bible that
would prohibit you from taking this I
don't know if you'd be violated if you
know if you're taking a pill that is
going to help prolong your life a
reverse aging well you know God in the
Garden of Eden he had something called
the tree of life that would perpetuate
life I don't think there's any moral
dilemma in taking medication that is
going to give you strength in life I
would not hold your breath if for that
pill but I can't what do you bet you
pasteurize I don't see where you'd be
breaking any kind of oh you know the
Bible talks about death being the enemy
that finally will be vanquished and God
created us to have life so taking care
of our bodies eating healthfully
exercising trying to prolong our life
both in years and quantity of life I
think is very appropriate mm-hmm
fantastic thank you very much and thank
the people that work by the scenes to
bring this program well thank you
appreciate your call god bless you
we have Lorraine's listening from
Spokane Washington Laureen welcome to
the program
hi thanks for having the program I have
a question and my husband and
Chevrolet's friend Joe haven't even had
him Bible study and they got to talking
about speaking in tongues and it
instantly divided the room half the
lived in it half said that it was that
it didn't it wasn't because you don't
know what you're saying
and my Reverend came and I said what
what is that mean
he said because if I can't he said I
believe that God is intelligent enough
to speak to me speak to me where I can
understand not where I'm going to babble
a bunch of stuff that I don't know what
I'm saying is right and is that being
good yeah
you know when I first came to the Lord I
worshiped with a church that practiced
the Pentecostal or example of speaking
in tongues where where they're you know
they're babbling and they call it a
prayer language but I didn't find it in
the Bible
if you look for instance in 1st
Corinthians 14 it says well let's see
what verse shall I go to if you go to
verse 9 so likewise except you utter by
the tongue where it's easy to understand
how it will it be known what is spoken
for you're speaking into the air and so
God says I'd rather spend five words
whereby my voice I might instruct others
in 10,000 in an unknown tongue so you
know the idea of speaking and not
understanding is the very thing that
Paul is saying we shouldn't do and
that's 1st Corinthians chapter 14 verse
1 through 5 so you know I've got a book
I can send you on that and it's called
understanding tongues if you'd like a
free copy pastor also tell you how to
order that all you're left to do just
give us a call the number to call is
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven
ask for the book called understanding
tongues we'll be happy to send that out
to you Lorraine or anybody who would
like to learn more about it one more
time eight hundred eight three five six
seven four seven is the number to call
thank you so much you're welcome you're
welcome thanks for calling
Mexico Lee is ray listening from North
Carolina ray welcome to the program ray
are you there I don't know if Ray's on
all right let's try Tina in Reno Nevada
Tina welcome to the program hey thank
you guys so much for having this program
thank you so my question is did Jesus
drink fermented wine in a word no I know
the Bible talks about Jesus turning
water to wine a person needs to keep in
mind there's a whole lot of great
juice in the Bible but it uses one word
to describe any kind of beverage made
from grapes it's all called wine and you
get the word wine from the fruit of the
vine and I think the word you'd find in
Greek is honest or onus but you can read
in is it Isaiah chapter 65 where it says
for as a new wine is in the cluster and
God says do not destroy it for there is
a blessing in it it talks about new wine
that's still in the cluster so in the
Bible Jesus said you don't put new wine
and old wine skins they're both called
wine the new wine was unfermented the
old wine was fermented so some people
argue when Jesus turned the water into
wine they say it was old wine the
fermented version but it's really hard
to picture Jesus in a wedding feast
making barrels of booze to get everybody
inebriated and do things that he
commands we should not do they said
you've saved the best for last and this
is John chapter 2 and I think the best
is unfermented yeah that was I actually
got into a conversation with my son who
argued with me that it was fermenting
and I'm like no I don't think it is but
I'm gonna ask faster then yeah and you
know there's one more verse you might
consider and if you look in Matthew it's
where Jesus is having the Last Supper
and he said I will not drink that wine
until I drink it with you new and my
father's kingdom even at the Last Supper
Jesus referred to the wine that he gave
the disciples as new wine so the body of
Christ is represented by unfit was
unleavened bread and his blood was
unfermented wine because they both are
symbols of purity so yeah and I've got a
book we do yes it's called the Christian
and alcohol and we'll be happy to send
us anybody who'd like to learn more or
you'll have to do is give us a call on
our resource phone line that's eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven and you can ask for the book
called at the Christian and alcohol
we'll be happy to send it to anybody who
calls and asks a next caller that we
have we're gonna try ray again ray in
North Carolina ray welcome to the
program
thank you I hear you now all right I do
have a question my question is that why
are there Christians who think that the
experience of the repentant thief on the
cross was one that teaches that one need
not be baptized to be saved if it seems
to me from Saint Matthew chapter three
verse five and six that many of the
people or maybe all the people around
Jerusalem and Judea and Jordan were
baptized by John the Baptist at least a
great majority of them apparently were
baptized and I would think that it seems
quite conceivable that the repentant
thief on the cross is one of them well
it is true that a lot of people from the
area of Jerusalem and Judea went and
were baptized by John but as you
mentioned those are people who had
repented of their sins the fact that he
is now being convicted of three things
that are mentioned one it says a thief
another time it says a rebel or mal
factor another place that says guilty of
murder
now we don't know if that was just
Barabbas or Barabbas and his two
companions but I do believe the baptism
is important I don't believe we can use
the thief on the cross to decide whether
or not you should be baptized the last
thing it says in the Bible is in Matthew
chapter 16 sorry mark 16 he says go
teach all nations baptizing them whoever
believes in this baptized will be saved
whoever believes not will be damned or
condemned and jesus said go in teach all
nations baptizing in the name of the
Father Son and Holy Spirit in John he
says unless you're born of the water and
the spirit you cannot enter the kingdom
of God so you know anyone who diminishes
baptism doesn't understand now are there
exceptions will there be people in
heaven that there's a record that they
weren't baptized of course you've got
you know a whole Old Testament full of
patriarchs that will be in heaven
doesn't record that they all practice
baptism and so the idea that baptism is
you know you nobody's going to be
allowed in heaven without baptism if a
person's in a hospital
and they're connected to medical
machines and they accept Jesus in the
last hours of their life you can't say
well the hospital's not going to
accommodate a baptism so they sorry we
can't save you Jesus will give them
credit for his baptism at that point but
those are rare exceptions if a believer
can be baptized why wouldn't he or she
want to be yes I understand your
sentiments I think also the repentant
thief when the cross
fits in with the spirit of baptism as
mentioned in Romans 6 being crucified
with Christ literally yeah had made it
put him in a special place where I think
there's much teaching about baptism just
in the fact that he was crucified with
Christ and he went through a great
change of heart
and a lot of repentance and a desire to
know Christ and keep on knowing Christ I
think there's a lot of T's right of
baptism with the repentant thief and it
does not negate the importance of
baptism exactly you know I've got a book
I'll be happy to send you if you'd like
a copy and as talks about the importance
of baptism some to cold baptism is it
really necessary and we'll be saying
happy to send it to anyone who calls and
asks very important subject the number
to call is 883 five six seven four seven
and again you can just ask for the book
called baptism is it really necessary
our next caller that we have is Delana
listening from California Delana welcome
to the program hi good get real close to
your phone okay can you hear me now yep
okay I have a question I was studying on
your the Bible being a up TV media
library the Bible study you have yes and
I got stuck on this course I was very
concerned about this okay Luke 23 55 56
the women I believe Galilee where Jesus
was from they put oil oils and spices on
him and then Luke 24 one two three the
resurrection day they came back
okay is the reason they came they went
back to do that the same process was it
because um they believed that the spirit
would come back into the body without
that Jewish customs do they believe that
no and I'm sorry I didn't mean to
interrupt you I was just going to say
you read that they did not finish the
task of embalming him because the
Sabbath was coming so they stopped they
went home and kept the Sabbath according
to the commandment which is you read in
verse 56 then they came back with
additional spices that they had acquired
early Sunday morning and come they
intended to complete the job that's why
they needed the stone rolled away so
they could finish in balmy in the body
it started out that Joseph of Arimathea
and Nicodemus they bought a hundred
pounds of myrrh before his burial to
begin the process they would dip the
cloth in myrrh and they'd wrap the body
yeah but they hadn't finished and so the
women came back with some additional
spices and they were gonna finish
embalming him and lo and behold he had
risen okay I was asking that cuz I know
my family when my mom passed away in the
house they said her spirit was hovering
around and then like my sister came
overseas like I felt Mama's spirit yeah
oh my god it's gonna be scary in the
last day so I'm studying it so hard so I
can try to help but I know that's a
sentimental thought but there's nothing
in the Bible that says that the spirit
hangs out in some limbo between death
and the resurrection so that's like
familiar spirit exactly yeah you know we
they're people so you can communicate
with the dead or have a seance or
whatever and Bible says we shouldn't get
into those dark arts at all but I have
you know one last thing well I'm before
my mother dies she was like she was
still alive I spoke to her and I went
home I just couldn't see her pass away
and then since I got home see so
d-definitely she called me take care of
your dad and you know be strong blah
blah blah and then my brother call like
30 minutes later says she died I'm like
and people keep telling me in the south
of the class that the day I can't speak
but I keep calling them she was not dead
which when I heard this and when I heard
this yeah my mind my spirit or something
well yeah you know sometimes maybe she
was praying and an angel whisper to you
I it's it's hard to say what causes an
impression like that but anyway well hey
we do have a lesson that talks about
this subject did you Michael it's simply
cold are the dead really dead this is
one of our amazing facts study guides
and of course we'll be happy to send
this to anyone who calls and asks all
you have to do is give us a call for the
number he's 883 five six seven four
seven and again you can ask for the
study guide cold are the dead really
dead and we'll be happy to send it out
to anyone who calls and asks well
listening friends you can tell we're
gonna have our mid time break when it
reminds you if you've got to the
internet you want to watch the program
as well as listen you can go to the
Facebook page be right back
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
amazing facts offer some of the best
Christian resources for all ages we have
our products will enrich your life and
your walk with the Lord
dad a subject everyone thinks about but
no one enjoys talking about is there
life after death the afterlife mystery
is a brand new sharing magazine that
answers all your questions get yours
today by calling 855-578-6767
call equipping soul-winners setting the
world ablaze for god can't get enough
amazing facts Bible study you don't have
to wait until next week to enjoy more
truth filled programming visit the
amazing facts media library at aft vor G
at aft vor G you can enjoy video and
audio presentations as well as printed
material all free of charge
24 hours a day seven days a week right
from your computer or mobile device
visit aft vor G every Bible question you
have answered moves you one step closer
to the fullness of God's will for your
life so what are you waiting for get the
answers you need for a fuller richer
more confident life you're listening to
Bible answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 my name is
John Ross good evening friends and pass
today we gonna go straight to the phone
lines we've got another caller that's
waiting we've got a reasoner listening
from the Southeast United States reason
and welcome to the program hi pastors
how are you doing thanks for taking my
call I got two questions for you in both
of them are
ezq the first one is in Ezekiel chapter
28 verse 12 through I'd say 14 and that
verse is talking about the attributes
well I hate to say this but the
attributes of Lucifer okay and in the
13th verse it says you were in Eden this
is sounding like he was in Eden before
he failed and if you go on down in the
verse around 14 - said you were the
anointed cherub you're in the mountain
of God and some other things that happen
before he failed am I reading this
correct that's the first question well I
don't think you should read the the
account of Lucifer in Ezekiel and it is
an account of Lucifer thinking it's all
sequential I think he's saying you had
everything going for you and now Lucifer
of course wasn't Eden but he was in the
Garden of Eden after his fall so because
he was there attempting the our first
parents and it describes him as he was a
beautiful you know angel it describes
all of the beautiful stones that covered
him you know some of the same stones
that you would find on the high priest
actually are mentioned in this passage
okay that's okay I didn't read that way
but okay then the second thing is over
in Ezekiel 29 Israel has left Egypt they
have their own nation Egypt did
something to really make the Lord get
upset with him over in here and I'm
trying to figure out what exactly
happened because I mean he said in verse
9 and 29 9 he was going to make them
desolate okay I'm like what did they do
it seemed like they were brands with the
Israelites what happened here well there
was a that's you're right there was a
period of time where there was peace
between Egypt and Israel in fact Solomon
helped seal that peace that began with
David in Israel
Solomon married the daughter of the
Pharaoh
it was his principal wife they had a it
went off and on but they had a pretty
good understanding between Judah and
Israel but then before Ezekiel
Neko came through the land of Israel he
was actually on his way to attack
Babylon and Josiah went out to fight
against him and they killed King Josiah
and he was one of the best kings if not
the best king it doesn't record anything
he did wrong that Israel ever had and
and they raided the temple at that time
and so there's a lot that Egypt did to
oppress Israel before Babylon came to
oppress them matter of fact it was Egypt
that not only did they kill Josiah they
took one of his sons captive and he died
in Egypt where Nebuchadnezzar then took
some of the other sons and they went to
Egypt so there was a renewed war between
Egypt and Israel
just before Ezekiel made those
prophecies and what's interesting the
prophecy came true because part of the
prophecy said you will be littlest among
the nations where they were the world
empire at one time from that point on
the temples all imploded they never rose
again to be a great nation and yet
Israel has been destroyed and rebuilt 27
times okay all right hey thank you great
question next caller that we have is
Tyler listening from Oklahoma City Tyler
you on the air hi my name is Tyler
Oklahoma City I'm 12 and my question is
in March going on okay mark 948 it talks
about a worm that never dies is this
worm real or is it symbolic it's
symbolic now keep in mind let me tell
you what Jesus is talking about and even
when he says it he may be looking at it
pastor Ross and I were in Israel
together a couple months ago now and we
looked at the Valley of Hinnom sometimes
it was called Gehenna outside of cities
back then they had dumps you didn't you
know have a garbage truck that would
pick things up people had wagons that
would haul things out they'd find a deep
useless Valley where nothing was growing
usually a rocky valley and they dumped
the trash in there to keep it from
filling up they'd also burn it there was
rotten food there were dead animals it
was just awful sometimes there was smoke
coming up so Jesus points to Gehenna
and he said you're better if you were
going to heaven missing the hand to
footer I then going into Gehenna where
the fire is not quenched nobody ever put
out the fire in Gehenna they wanted to
keep burning to keep the smell down
where the fire is not quenched in the
worm or the maggot doesn't die meaning
there's it's always full of maggots so
Jesus is using that as an illustration
of where the Lost would go a place of
uncleanness a place of suffering and
darkness so no it's not talking about
little war worms that live forever and
ever thank you
that's a great question you know we do
have a study that talks about is the
devil in charge of Hell and it talks
about the word Gehenna it'll give you
the four words used for Hell in the
Bible and all their definitions you'll
enjoy it and it's Illustrated you'll
really like it if you'd like to get it
all you're left to do is call our
resource phone line that's eight hundred
eight three five six seven four seven
and you can ask for the study guide
called and did God create a devil and
Tyler I'm just thinking you mentioned
you 12 you might not have seen this
before
if not you might want to take a look at
it two things number one we have a video
called cosmic conflict that kind of
talks about the origin of evil and talks
about finally how the righteous will be
victorious we also have a set of study
guides gear just for kids called amazing
adventure very popular and that's also
available through amazing facts so I
wanted to let you know about that next
caller that we have is Edwin listening
from Vancouver British Columbia
Edwin welcome to the program is we're
glad you're here yeah and your question
tonight
okay my question is regarding revelation
5 when you're with a look and see all
the books Dylan why what is this book
and what is the importance of this book
that he was crying so hard because no
one who opened the book on to the lion
Judah lie on top except the Lion of
Judah yes I tell you what pastor rusty
pastor oz has a special love for
revelation
you want to explain what the book is and
why everyone's yeah we'll we'll share a
little bit about it it's a great chapter
chapter 5 is a description of the
heavenly throne room actually starts in
chapter 4 and chapter 5 chapter 5 got
the father you seen holding a scroll
sealed with seven seals and no one's
able to open this book or the scroll
except for Christ the lamb appears
before the throne slain from the
foundation of the earth and because no
one was found worthy to open the book
this is before Jesus appears John weeps
much so folks have wondered what is it
about this book that was so important
there is a book in Revelation that is
especially ascribed to Christ and it's
called the Lamb's Book of Life and there
are a number of scholars that feel that
this book that each seals broken reveals
a different phase in the great
controversy but ultimately is the
promise for everlasting life for those
who receive Christ as they save you amen
and you know do we have anything toxic
we don't have a book about the book of
life do we we don't have a book
specifically that deals with that we had
a magazine on Revelation though we do
dange and revelation if you'd like to
learn more about that give us a call the
number is 883 five six seven four seven
and you can ask for the magazine on The
Book of Revelation
next caller that we have is Anna
listening from California and a welcome
to the program hello hi thank you for
calling hi pastor Doug my question is um
regarding birthday celebrations I have a
friend who does not celebrate her
birthday because she claims that it is a
pagan ritual and to me I just can't
imagine God not being happy about
somebody you know birthday the day that
he puts them on this earth why that
wouldn't be a joyous occasion so my
question is is it really is she right is
it really pagan and we shouldn't be
celebrating our birthdays well you know
I don't know if anywhere in the Bible
where it says that we shouldn't
celebrate a birthday sometimes they'll
look at the story of Herod
I think Herod it was on his birthday
that John the Baptist got beheaded and
they say I'll see it must be evil but
you can also read in the book of Joel
that job's seven sons and three
daughters would get together on their
various birthdays and celebrate together
taking time to thank God for a landmark
whether it's your wedding anniversary or
your birthday is not worshipping a pig
in God now I know this same church
they'll say you know we shouldn't
celebrate Christmas or Easter they could
probably make a stronger argument about
a pig in connection with you know the
days of Christmas and Easter but I don't
birthdays me I don't even think there's
any connection there so I just wonder
where she got that idea then well
they're Church I'm acquainted with what
church this is in their church they try
to make a case that birthdays are pagan
and they'll point to like I said the
point to King Herod did it and so it
must be pagan well just because a pagan
doesn't it does something nowhere in the
Bible is to say thou shalt not celebrate
birthdays or anything like that so yeah
nothing wrong with having an occasion
you could you can get together and
praise the Lord and thank him for
anything okay wonderful
matter of fact God God has every year
God had seven annual feasts designed to
help people thank God and remember
points of their Exodus so God had no
problem with having memorials on an
annual basis to remember things and so
yeah I think that's a weak argument
wonderful oh thank you very much faster
done all right thank you appreciate your
question we have spree Annie listening
from Dallas Texas spree Annie welcome to
the program you're there yeah I know how
do you say your name I am so sorry it's
pronounced Brianna
okay we got an SP on the front for some
reason and your question tonight can you
hear us can you hear me now that's
better yeah
and your question I'm sorry I don't know
I guess my phone is kind of going out
can you hear me that we can so what ask
you a question quickly in case we lose
you at least we can answer on the air
okay so my question basically is
regarding a Matthew the 17th chapter
verse 14 through 18 and I was wondering
I know that there are deliverance
ministries out there that I go on and I
was wondering if if there are times
where a demon actually in a person that
they have to both like a longer like
deliverance session you know in order to
expel the demon out because I know in
verse 18 it says in Jesus rebuked the
devil and he departed out of him and the
child was cured from that very hour so
how come he was cure from the very hour
of yet there are people who have to go
through like deliverance sessions for
like hours and maybe some people much
well I'll tell you an even biblical yeah
the the reason is if you look in verse
20 of the same chapter
the disciples later asked Jesus why were
we unsuccessful in casting out the demon
that's in verse 19 jesus said because of
your unbelief I said you know if you
have faith you can move mountains and
then look at verse 21 he said however
this kind does not go out except prayer
and fasting well prayer and fasting is
not something to do in 10 minutes I
think everybody listening fast ten
minutes there's not no problem in that
he's talking about sometimes when a
person struggling with some kind of
demonic oppression or a power that may
take several days of praying that that
doesn't mean you've got a session where
all the church gathers around them and
they're yelling and screaming and laying
hands on them for days I don't think
that's what he's talking about there
there are people who are struggling and
you might need to take days to pray for
him it might require fasting in prayer
Bible says Jesus casts Seven Devils out
of Mary Magdalene and it doesn't sound
like it happened all at once so you know
Christ could always do things instantly
he could just speak the word and it
would happen but yeah as far as these
demonic sessions where people go through
extra citizens I don't see that in the
Bible whenever Paul prayed the Devils
came out when he rebuked that
demon-possessed girl where's at Acts
chapter 16 it happened right away
hey I think you appreciate your question
next hold that we have is Becky listen
from Michigan Becky you on the program
yes I am
hello there how are you good thank you
for calling I want to make a comment I
watch the heroes of safe the series and
I read the book I liked very much very
inspiring thank you and I have a
question from this a biblical point what
is assurance well assurance is a
confidence and you're talking especially
it was like assurance of salvation you
know the Lord tells us that we need to
believe when we pray and ask him to
forgive us we need to believe that he
will forgive us that he does hear our
prayers and that's where we find joy and
knowing that and believing that he does
forgive us if we always are worried that
you know well I'm just not good enough
and I'll and we think about the negative
side it kind of takes all the joy away
so is am i answering your question about
assurance you still they are Becky yes
I'm still here I think your mom's phone
fraud oh my yeah dude that make sense
did you hear me yes it did it makes
sense so when God promises something a
matter of fact you know what I've got a
book I'll send you and it's called a
justification assurance made simple and
so we'll send you that book on assurance
if you'd like a free copy we could
either send it to you or you could read
it online by going to the amazing facts
website all you have to do is give us a
call on the resource phone line that
number again is 883 five six seven four
seven you can answer the book called
assurance justification made simple
we'll be happy to send that out to
anyone who calls and asks a next caller
that they have is Laura and listening
from New Mexico Laura welcome to the
program yes we have one question please
I want to know if King Solomon and Queen
Sheba conceived a child and what
happened to it there's no record in the
Bible that they had even a romantic
relationship most of that comes from
Hollywood there's a little tiny just a
little blurb like two sentences on
sure what book it was in but it says
that there came from the far corners of
the world
Queens yeah the Queen of Sheba did come
from a long way but it never says that
she and Solomon had a romantic
relationship it said she came to ask him
questions he answered her questions she
gave him gifts he gave her gifts they
made an alliance between the two
countries and she left there's not a
word in the Bible that they had anything
romantic going on and there's definitely
not a word in the Bible that they had a
baby together most of that came out of a
movie in Hollywood with Yul Brynner and
I forget who the leading lady was today
just today I was listening to a
Christian radio program and the pastor
brought it up and he did indicate that
there was a child so I was all confused
because I knew that I had seen the movie
and there was you know it did indicate
that they have yeah Hollywood always
tries to weave in some kind of romance
and the movie The Ten Commandments okay
yep no it was a purely platonic
relationship she was looking for wisdom
and he already had 300 wives he didn't
even get enough how Mexico loved that we
have is John listening from
Massachusetts John welcome to the
program good and your question yeah you
get I saw you have to get real close to
your phone like you broke up on us mark
you said you still there let's try one
more time
John you there hello hello yeah now we
hear you all right
you mentioned your question was from
mark mark 7 yeah mark 7 19 you guys can
hear me right yes now I can ok ok cool
all right
um so yeah Mark 719 can you can you read
that for me is that ok sure it says
because it does not enter his heart but
his stomach and is eliminated thus
purifying all foods what does that mean
does purifying our foods well Jesus is
talking to the disciples about are they
contaminated because they did
then ritually washed their hands before
they ate the religious leaders are
having an argument with him and Jesus
said this isn't what defiles your heart
says if you eat food and you get a
little dirt in your food he says you it
goes through your digestive system it is
purged and eliminated says it comes in
and it goes out he's trying to find a
graceful way to say that he said that
doesn't defile you and then the
purifying all foods
yeah crisis I kinda sounds like I'm
sorry go ahead
no I should say Jesus is saying that
your digestive system has a purging
mechanism in it you know your stomach is
actually hotter than the rest of your
body he's not saying he's not saying
that you're some people wonder if this
verse is saying that Jesus declared all
foods clean yeah yeah that's he that's
who but I heard that this verse was was
added to it at it in the ER well if
you've got a new international version
yeah yes it was which is actually from
your your arm
the amazing facts library sorry Denson
no it's okay yeah if you're reading from
the New International Version it adds
something that is not in the original
Greek they say insane this Jesus
declared all foods clean and the
original does not say that if they are
reading they've got a manuscript that
described put a parenthetical comment in
there and they're putting it in the
Bible Jesus did not declare all foods
clean and the reason we know that is
when you get to Acts chapter 10 Peter
sees this vision of food coming down and
there's unclean animals Peter says not
so Lord I have never eaten anything
common and unclean well no matter what
you think Peter's vision means Peter
definitely says that in 34 ad he still
has never eaten anything unclean so the
Apostles never got the idea from Jesus
that everything was cleansed okay and
you know I mean really does this mean
what Christian believes that you know
you can eat skunks and cockroaches and
buzzards and most of the foods that John
declared unclean are still unclean
people struggle with pork
that's pork in lobsters yeah no I'm
trying to I'm trying to give up pork
that that stuff is no good yeah I don't
know if you heard about in viral pig but
now there's placing my switch with pig
and and well that'd be a double curse
wouldn't it because Pig my friend clean
you know there's actually verse in the
Bible that said God is going to punish
those that eat them they're gonna those
that eat the abomination of the mouse
and the pig that's right do you think do
you think that could be that was what I
was talking about like yeah not no I
don't think that the prophecy was
talking about that but hey thank you
John appreciate it and you'll enjoy our
book called hogs and other hazards and
pastor also tell you about that yes all
you have to do is give us a call the
number is 883 five six seven four seven
you can ask for a book called hogs and
other hazards just a caching title their
next call that we have is Chris
listening from Chicago Illinois Chris
welcome to the program hi pastor pastor
oz evening um I have a question yep
hopefully I get this out okay um in
Exodus where Moses writes down the laws
and things that the Israelites shouldn't
do and what the punishments for mom are
do those still hold today
well the Ten Commandments certainly
still hold there are some Levitical laws
that were ceremonial in nature you're
not required to sacrifice lambs the
circumcision is not mandatory and there
were some other ceremonial laws so was
there a specific law you're wondering
about ah you know alright is it one that
you're concerned about having broken
yeah um let me add just an additional
fault there because you are right there
are some very stranger's consequences
for those who broke any of the Ten
Commandments sometimes there was even a
death penalty that was implemented but
we find Jesus extending grace in the
case of the woman caught committing
adultery in the Old Testament law she
should have been stoned
but Jesus provided forgiveness and said
go and sin no more so in the New
Testament where don't you know we don't
drag people out for stone them for
committing adultery or something like
that there are consequences to breaking
God's law but the penalty is different
God's the one that ultimately judges
each person based upon their works so I
just wanted that clarification because
New Testament times you don't find
people executing others for breaking one
of the commandments other than the one
laughs about kill yeah but I guess what
I'm wondering is if you broken some of
these laws in the Bible where it says
here if remembering correctly - there's
been a while since I read it just didn't
know who to ask um if you're it seemed
to me like if you broke some of these
that you were just automatically damned
well you know the only thing that you're
automatically doomed for is if you
commit the unpardonable sin and so Chris
there's good news for you that the very
fact that you're feeling some remorse
right now and it sounds like that Jesus
will forgive you he'll provide mercy and
you know that's one of the main reasons
we do this program is to encourage
people with the good news of the gospel
that Jesus forgives sin and that means
in order to appreciate the gospel you
need to be a sinner and it sounds like
you're admitting that you qualify accept
the forgiveness Jesus died in your place
ask him for a new beginning I've got a
free book I'll give you and it's called
what is the unpardonable sin so you'll
know what that is and what it isn't and
all you have to do is call amazing facts
and we'll send that to you listening
friends and I do apologize if it seems
like we had to rush you off running out
of time we pray that you will keep us in
your prayers
you can go to amazing facts dot o-r-g
god bless
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
[Music]
deep within the pages of the Bible
stories of great heroes heroes of great
deeds great love and great sacrifice but
behind them is another hero hidden in
plain sight amid the shadows he was
there from the beginning
and he'll be there until the end
discover the golden thread of a savior
woven throughout the entire bible
tapestry
shadows of light seeing Jesus in all the
Bible get your copy today by calling
written by the hand of God and spoken
with his voice
some words will never fade
[Music]
yet pastor Doug bachelors twelve part
sermon series on the Ten Commandments by
calling 805 to seventy five terror
attacks natural disasters political
instability and global economic meltdown
these are the images people generally
associate with the tribulation and the
day of the Lord but did you know the
Bible speaks about another day of the
Lord just before the great Judgment Day
amazingly imprinted on the very fabric
of time itself is a 24-hour period
called the Sabbath that was meant to
forever be a time of restoration for
every human being a day the entire world
is largely forgotten you'll be surprised
to learn how this special day of the
Lord
factors into last day prophecies such as
the mark of the beast the seal of God
and the great final tribulation it's all
contained in this new eye-opening DVD
series called the last day of prophecy
to order call 800 538 7 to 75 in six
days God created the heavens and the
earth for thousands of years man has
worshiped God on the seventh day of the
week now each week millions of people
worship on the first day what happened
why did God create a day of rest does it
really matter what day we worship who is
behind this great shift discover the
truth behind God's law and how it was
changed visit Sabbath truth calm for
over 50 years
amazing faxes shared the wonderful news
of salvation and provided millions of
Bible resources to people all over the
world we've built churches in India
proclaim God's Word in China and have
sent free Bible studies around the globe
today's program and three resources were
made possible by our ministry partners
caring individuals like you if you've
been blessed by amazing facts would you
please consider partnering with us to
reach others with the Bible truth your
financial support today will help keep
programs like this on the air so the
blessings you've received can be shared
with others if you'd like to enhance
your study of God's Word visit our
website at WWF a go RG